[Music]
stanford university
please welcome our guest riley brennan
riley is a founding partner a general
partner at trucks vc a
seed stage rental capital fund for
entrepreneurs changing the future of
transportation
trucks riley has invested in
transformational mobility companies such
as autonomy now emotional crews javier
aviation and actually many more
prior to drugs
riley was executive director for
stanford's automotive research program
and still when
in-person participation allows
also teaches the class
and he was a member of the le mans
winning factory corvette c5r program
thank you very much for joining us to
talk about this really hot space
yeah thanks martin thanks everybody for
having me i really appreciate
being here with everybody obviously i
love stanford
primarily because i didn't get into
stanford as a high school student and so
being able to come back and
teach at stanford is just one of life's
great pleasures
yeah i probably wouldn't have gotten any
as a high school student i think we
share that and but yeah thank you for
the contributions you have made are
still making to the stanford community
stanford just as a aside
i really
started life as a car guy like with
posters of race cars on my wall and
it was when i got to stanford about a
decade ago that i started to have my
eyes open to
transportation and other ideas beyond
just the car
and my fund is really the genesis of my
fund which we can talk about
was hanging around stanford and seeing
that there were a lot of founders
working on things that the car industry
wasn't working on and
that's the whole reason i have a fund
today so stanford played a huge part in
that okay you totally uh read my mind in
terms of the first question so we could
i was going to ask you like how yeah did
you always know you wanted to get into
this space but yeah so you answered that
i wanted to start with a small anecdote
i read on one of the stanford web pages
that your land speed record is 168 miles
per hour
driving presumably yeah and and i have
to admit that i chickened out at 146
miles per hour and my father's a8 on the
autobahn in germany
so i thought okay that's fast enough
yeah where did you drive 168 was that
the limo and how was the how was it
that was at a decommissioned air force
base in the lower peninsula of michigan
so
there's a great
old air base called oscoda and it's used
for
race car testing shakedown tests and
things like that
and in a former life
when i was a lot younger i was a
journalist and
i reviewed cars so actually when i was
an undergrad at university of michigan
my job was to test drive cars it was
really fun
and a little bit after that i was
running this media organization
and i had the opportunity to drive a k m
car which for anybody
who's followed racing is like the most
extreme
no rules racing from the 60s and 70s
and this one particular car i really
loved called the chaparral
i got to drive this one car
yeah at this track
and i didn't
bend the car and i didn't
hurt myself so i've considered a mission
accomplished because i'm not a race car
driver i'm just an enthusiast that got
an opportunity once to do that
so yeah it was really fun and it also
proved to me like the differences
between those who are really good at
doing something like that and an
interloper like myself
there's a huge amount of daylight right
so the people who actually go out and
almost like the way you think about an
experimental aircraft
pilot
is so different from somebody flying a
drone in their backyard that's what i'm
like
yeah i started that because i wanted to
start our discussion with talking about
your vision for transportation and
mobility but first maybe explain how you
see the difference between
transportation and mobility
it seems like these terms are thrown
around
almost interchangeably which was a bit
of a surprise as i back into this as a
civil engineer
i focus on stuff that doesn't move so
we'll come back to that later but maybe
before we get to the vision how do you
differentiate between transportation
mobility
that's a great question martin and i
like to use the term transportation and
not mobility
and i think it's because in the last
five years
there have been a lot of
people that have come in and just looked
at different business models and
a lot of
maybe not so much
over the last year but
two and three years ago
every idea and mobility every idea that
was mobility related seemed to be shared
use like business models and
although that stuff was interesting i
didn't think it really encompassed all
the wide variety of things you could do
in the space which
not scientifically i think transpiration
is a better word for that
and it's also by the way
the reason why i think transportation is
a great place to
invest money or spend your time because
at any one time
the market can be up in one part of
transportation and down in another and
this is particularly true of things like
if you follow
new car sales they might be down and
when that happens used car sales are up
and service and mains maintenance
businesses go up in value
and i've always loved that part about
transportation which i don't think is
well captured with just the term
mobility so
it's not that i hate the term mobility i
just try to use the term transportation
more no actually no it makes sense to me
because transportation is broader
mobility seems to focus on people and
transportation is really you can imagine
lots of things there
but so how do you foresee
the future are we going to zip around in
100 all well coordinated at 168 miles
per hour
i've heard other visions that focus on
zero accidents or affordability and
dramatic improvement in affordability i
could see reliability
quality of experience on transparency i
could see many aspects of that vision
what also some hallmarks for
how we will experience transportation in
the future or maybe if you prefer to
share some vivid examples of how our
lives might be affected or different
better
in
five ten years
yeah
at the core i think
this decade is going to be defined by
zero emission transportation so
it's a
what a wonderful place to spend your
time if you're a researcher you're an
entrepreneur
and i think of transportation as one of
these
i remember my chemistry teacher in high
school used to say what in the world
isn't chemistry
and to some extent when you get into the
into the modern world what isn't
impacted by transportation and you can
if you think about companies in this
space they need policy people and
business people and designers and
there's just so much that transportation
touches i know i sound like a bit of a
cheerleader for this category but i do
think it's just worthwhile to think of
it like that and so for us we're always
interested in
we have these three goals for our
investments they should make
transportation safer
cleaner and more accessible
and for me the accessibility piece is
really
what technology tends to do pretty well
which is that ideas generally start
looking a little bit strange sometimes
it might be a little expensive
and eventually they're actually brought
into really low cost
and transportation unfortunately i think
we have to face the fact that
a lot of the things that we've made
cheap like parking and credit have also
created a lot of other geometry problems
and health problems for us so
what are the ways that we can enable
zero emission low cost simple
transportation options and the reality
of it is a lot of
great technology would have probably
been better served in a city just by
putting in bike lanes
so
this is one of the fascinating parts of
being in transportation is that
everybody has a different opinion about
the right way to i think everybody's got
a different recipe for making cookies
and when you think about how people
were if you were to plan out
transportation and how a city should be
using all these resources
it's similar that you have some people
who have a strong dogma that you need
this much amount of floured sugar
and i think that the balance in the
united states has clearly been designed
automobiles and
we have
created a lot of freedom but we've also
created a lot of problems
and so
that's what's wonderful about some of
these new things we've seen is that
transportation is a great leverage to to
do better things particularly with
cities
there's actually a couple threats i want
to pick up on one is the accessibility
in particular
and
one is on diversity and the other one on
the different
types of cities you find in the world
and maybe you pick up there and to what
extent to international to what extent
does international potential i know
you've focused the fronts of how mostly
in north america but to what extent does
international potential
drive your decisions and to what extent
have you seen international influences
in the ideas that get pitched to you i'm
just reflecting on an experience in
copenhagen a few years ago on a very
dark january morning and that was my
hotel was in the side street and i
thought i have plenty of time just a
short taxi right away
what i had not factored in is that it
would take us literally 10 minutes to
get out of the side street onto the main
street
because there was an uninterrupted flow
of bicycles and before the blizzard
happening it was dark the wind was
blowing snow was falling and we could
not we had to literally wait ten minutes
until there was a gap in the bicycles
right you would think this should happen
in palo alto but no that's that in in
copenhagen i thought okay this is a
different attitude and then i research
in the half of the professional
community regardless of whether happens
with my bicycles there
and anyway so a very different the
experiences of around the world
obviously and i'm sure many other cities
we could mention um so to what extent
does this
international potential and versus and
also ideas that come from elsewhere i
guess it's true question how much do you
see international ideas influence or
international experience shape ideas and
to what extent
is the potential for globalization of
some of your technologies driver in your
investment decision
i would say that
my own personal
sort of
travels which unfortunately haven't done
much of you know recently
have influenced it a lot and i think
that
some of the things we see in some other
cities you mentioned copenhagen is the
perfect example
i think a lot of people a lot of young
people wish
my city looked a lot more like that and
i think of it like the
halloween candy test would you allow
your kids to safely
traipse through your neighborhood
without having to hold their hand the
whole time and is the geometry of your
city such that
you feel comfortable with your
eight-year-old going for a bike ride and
if the answer to that is no you've got
to really ask some serious questions
about how we're allocating space
from a truck's perspective i think
one of the things that
i'm really interested in is like new
global ev brands like i think that to
assume that tesla is kind of the only
ev brand is really short selling the
future
and so rivien would be maybe another
example but
in the light electric vehicle category
for bicycles
i think there'll be some amazing brands
created this decade and some of them
might be in
like for example i think
when india goes electrified it will be a
two and three wheel
product
not a four-wheeled tesla that changes
india to electrification
and
also i think if you take a look at a
brand like van moof which is a dutch
e-bike brand it's quite early days but
it's not hard for me to imagine how they
move five or ten years from now is
actually a really dominant global e-bike
light electric vehicle brand so
i'm really fascinated by that and
because of the way that some of these
vehicles can be built and some of the
supply chain which is already global in
some way
i actually think we're going to see
new brands start from
seed from seedlings as opposed to big
companies like gm or
nissan start building exceptional bikes
and small vehicles
[Music]
and the other aspect but i was frankly a
little bit stunned i don't know what you
students thought the reading we did and
what we read as background for the class
but i was a reflection i had about the
reading
how it seemed one size fits all kind of
approach i i at least i felt there
should have been much more consideration
of diversity
for different
age groups for different people with
different abilities and so forth so i
was a little stunned what was the
reading
by the lack of that there's a couple
readings from sidewalk labs and one from
lyft we'll come to that predicting we'll
have lots of autonomous lift vehicles
this year and then one for mckenzie on
the sort of smart city
okay
and and that was because i really loved
seeing
your statement about the will never
speak on the mantle
folks that didn't see that statement the
panel that has only men on it and then
and here are a couple hundred women that
are doing great things in the space so
don't come with the excuse we can't find
somebody and so that made me think about
their diversity and i was wondering to
what extent um is that a factor when you
choose an investment does and does do
you get pitched a lot is that on the
horizon at all or is it
not there on the horizon but should be
yeah
we yeah so just to set the stage
i don't think that four and five people
discussions are
actually
that valuable to me personally anyway
and
one of the things that i've realized
about it is i feel that way probably
because i've been over invited to things
and when we really did like an audit of
the this is going back four or five
years ago
this sort of typical auto show or
innovation panel it was usually just
white men from the auto industry talking
about the auto industry
and one of the things we came up with as
a fund was
why don't we just tell these people who
are organizing these events i'll do it
but if you also have a woman on stage
this is what we call the inverse of the
mike pence rule who famously
wouldn't participate in wouldn't go to
dinner with one other woman or something
like that we would say that and then
people would say to us
that's fine but i don't know any women
in the audience like they would
literally say that and so we got so
frustrated from hearing that we were
like i guess we have to create a
database
of great women in transportation because
it would shut that argument up quickly
so we did that if you go to
women.trucks.vc
there's a couple hundred amazing
executives there and
categorized therefore we can give them
that resource and i always give up my
spot if there's a four four-person panel
and
there's not a woman on it so that's just
like a company-wide policy we have and
in the auto industry particularly
there's
there's a really
incredible disparity between if you look
at the executives most of these teams
other than
the exceptions you have maribora and
stuff like that
most of the old school detroit
and european auto industries are run by
uh white men and then in venture i would
say that the numbers are a little bit
better but that's not saying much
because the auto industry is so awful
with these with the diversity numbers
they have so our portfolio is indicative
of probably
just startups in general which are a
little bit more diverse
what we have is rule at trucks is we
say if there's a diverse founder
we'll let them move through the first
the first gate in our process
so that we make sure we do a call with
them because
one of the things that trucks is we do a
qualification step before we talk to
founders
and
the qualification step is really just to
simplify our funnel and it's like hey
are they raising the right amount of
money are they
is it still a seed round is there enough
of the seed
round available for us to invest
and it's actually a pretty hard filter
because it cuts out
at least half of the companies we see
if there's a founder from that team
who's who basically checks one of the
boxes for diversity inclusion on our
side then we'll do a first call with
them anyway just because we feel like
it's our job to
make
the numbers in this whole like
automotive world a lot better and since
we have such an important part of it
which is that we're funding companies
it's important for us to to do that and
we have a lot of diverse founders about
a third of our portfolio has a woman or
a person of color as a leader in the
company usually a c level and a founder
[Music]
i think that's pretty cool
yeah looking it's actually just weird
that nobody else
in in the auto space does stuff like
this it should be relatively normal but
and i'm not saying it like to put any
other people down
it's just one of those like obvious
things
like saying thank you when somebody
opens the door for you or something like
that where you're like that's kind of
what that should be pretty normal
so
we have a small part to play we fund
about eight companies a year
and i wish my other colleagues from
the other automotive venture capital
funds would do the same
yeah still over the years you have
quite a portfolio i have to admit i
didn't
manage to look through every one of the
companies you invested in or currently
invested but i'm curious what
breakthroughs
are you most excited to get us towards
the zero emission the more accessible
division sure
uh for the first time we've made energy
investments in the last year and we
usually just
to be honest martin usually our
investments were
if it moved the
vehicle itself like a lot of autonomy
investments
sensors maybe things related to risk
and driver monitoring but
a lot of it was stuff you would expect
on a
automated vehicle
and for the first time this year we did
over the last 12 months we've done stuff
which is just
really touching the energy side of it so
we did a low cost silicon anode
we just did our first hydrogen
investment which is a hydrogen storage
and distribution
system would remind you of
nespresso or keurig in the sense that
the ip is in the container to move
hydrogen as opposed to it's not a
hydrogen generation station or something
like that
so
i think one of the challenging parts to
answer your question is
there are probably going to be different
types of energy you need for different
applications
and far
it's going to be really expensive so if
you're
you know let's say your ford motor
company or your daimler maybe down
there's a better example because
diameter sells really small cars they
sell
delivery vans they sell big trucks in
the way of
freightliner they own
and they have to have powertrains which
at least three different types of
powertrains across the whole spectrum so
they probably will need
a range of battery electric vehicles
they probably need a range of hybrids
in the truck category still running
diesel
eventually they need to run hydrogen or
something in long-haul trucking
and that's just really expensive that
type of powertrain development
so that's to me
this decade will be defined by that it
will also crumble a few companies i'm
not
saying that dumbled the diameter is
going to crumble because of this task
but
it's going to be a herculean effort if
you're one of these kind of full-line
companies to address all these
powertrain energy problems
or opportunities one is how these
different energy ideas will impact
different segments in transportation and
i think that aviation is going to go the
same way that
we'll have vtols that are short distance
that are electric and then eventually
probably using some hydrogen there as
well so i think that's
for me that's going to be amazing to
watch over the next decade the other
thing which i think is really important
is
just the idea that we can make great
lightweight
urban
vehicles with a fun sense of vehicle
dynamics so
one of the one of my passions growing up
as a kid was could i get to the chance
to drive that chaparral race car
and
the folly of a lot of these like sports
cars is you need a lot of money and you
need a ton of room to run them
so the opportunity for somebody to go
out and actually have fun
in one of these cars like you have to go
either at a racetrack or you need to
break the law in order to experience
what it's been designed to do
and i think the other really interesting
opportunity is can you have
given congestion in cities
can you have really great vehicle
dynamics experiences
in smaller vehicles it's actually a
really hard engineering challenge for
if you if we were at porsche we wanted
to create
a small one-seater vehicle for cities
but i think that would be a really cool
exercise right now you can do a really
interesting version of that in a bicycle
but what are those interesting small
vehicle experiences where you don't have
to go 180 miles an hour you could be
going 18 miles an hour
and you feel something magical and i'm
really excited about that which is both
a
it's an electric vehicle problem it's a
mechanical engineering problem so
those are two
um
looking at some of your companies i've
opened really my eyes to the sort of
many facets of transportation
and and then just how many advancements
are being made and still need to be made
and i was wondering how many of those
have to come together to create really a
significant change that we will notice
is there a lot of synergy yes i could
see there are synergies but what are
some synergies that you're particularly
excited about or maybe even worried
about better they will happen
but
yeah i mean i guess yeah sorry yeah no
one way to think about this is some of
the most impactful companies in this in
transportation
didn't need anybody else's permission
right waze and uber
didn't need daimler to say yes to
something for them to have a great
company and that's pretty cool
and so
there are totally
disruptive ideas which are completely
outside of the supply chain that people
will come up with over the next decade
and
i hope we fund those companies at trucks
then there's like these new ecosystems
where i'm only starting to
understand the different layers of value
so
a good example of that would be charging
and
like i thought i knew a lot about
charging until
three months ago and then i've realized
all the different
energy tariffs and
service contracts required to keep a
charger in great uptime
and all the stupid reasons why a charger
goes out of service and i've learned a
lot about the service layer around ev
chargers and i think that there's a
billion dollar company
in just that part about it within the
united states because of all the
charters we're going to have to put in
and
what's required so
i kind of
love the
i guess this is one of the best parts
about being an investor is that you get
to learn all these new sort of pockets
of
creation and then some of them you make
a bet on that you believe are going to
be really valuable that is a good
example i think of we have a couple of
different charging and battery related
investments
they don't all really need to talk to
one another
sometimes like to bring up the example
of a mckinsey deck
like now when i receive like a morgan
stanley paper on charging
i usually send it to
a few of our portfolio founders who are
in the battery or electrification space
and that list is just like growing
like more and more and what's cool is
that some of them talk to one another
even though they're not really related
one of them is doing ev charging as like
data science to plan where you put a
charger
another one is service
another one is doing batteries so
another one is battery management so
there's they're not really talking one
another but they're all in that same
ecosystem they benefit from
all the consumer push and the policy
push to move to
electric vehicles so
some of it is like nicely
intertwined and some of it isn't no
makes sense to me
as a civil engineer i have to we we get
we don't get so excited when our stuff
moves and and you get excited when your
things move and we don't
vice versa but i have to i'm wondering
how you see the relationship between
autonomous vehicles and the physical
infrastructure is it seen as just an
evolve as an enemy or something that
just has to be dealt with is there or is
it increasingly seen as a partner a
potential problem or in enabling
new kinds of transportation
and do you see
still mostly ideas pitch to you that
focus on
the stuff that moves or do you see ideas
that connect with the physical
infrastructure i see for example cord
strikes me as one of your investments
strikes me as a pretty clear connection
to the physical infrastructure
yeah where do you see that that relation
how do you see that relationship and how
do you see that continuing or growing or
changing in the future
transportation side
the so we tend to like
we call it structured autonomy meaning
you can run the same thing over and over
again preferably in a very
well defined area
sometimes if you go into agriculture or
construction
you do so without any passengers and you
do so
on private roads at low speed so
i think agriculture automation is
probably
one of the most perfect
like reasons that autonomy exists today
and you could go into mining or
construction and make similar arguments
but
so i think in the near term some of
these ideas that
people have been talking about for road
vehicles are probably going to be better
realized in those environments but when
it comes to infrastructure
i love structured autonomy companies
that use the same
route because you can get better at
an intersection you can
hang your own
sensor on a gantry or on a bollard or
something like that
and so like a good example would be
may mobility or refraction these are two
companies doing
a city
urban
av work in may's case they're doing a
shuttle and refraction it's a small
delivery robot and in both those
companies cases they're actually
putting something in the infrastructure
to make the job of the autonomy system
better
and you can only do that if you're doing
a structured autonomy business model if
you're just in this open
world of any point b out there that the
user tells you you really can't get to
those and so we love
using the infrastructure when we can
and then cord as a it's interesting
company because they're trying to create
this software layer between
the curb and some user whether it's a
ups truck or a cup for a restaurant if
you want to do a 90 second
curb space block say you can pick up
your food and things like that
and so that company's point of view
would be
think of every curb out there as a
revenue opportunity for cities
not just this fixed parking asset that
might go fallow in the middle of the
night yeah i think it's it's one of the
interesting parts about
this space is these different business
models can allow you to use the
infrastructure and i think probably most
famously
the micro mobility companies
have had so many infrastructure problems
because
scooters get you know left in the wrong
area or
they get penalized by the city because
they
actually can't manage where the things
are quite effectively
so it's a huge part of this yeah yeah
so i
i do have to talk about the predictions
people make and i have made plenty of
the predictions were right the time
frame was totally wrong
and that was i would say the same in
this article from lyft that i predicted
in 2021 we'll have many autonomous
vehicles in the lyft system we still
have a few months ago but i'm not sure
but very little car ownership by 2025
that the physical environment will
change
which strikes me well if you're not
shanghai in most places
things take a while as i talk with
people in planning apartments in cities
they have not only transportation varies
they have utility varies they need to
think about resilient sea level rise
what does that do so the transportation
infrastructure is not necessarily the
forefront
so i found that article a little bit uh
too self-serving but anyway i'm curious
how do well where do you
make predictions about uh what will
happen in five ten years and i'm totally
fine
i get it if you don't
i stopped doing that in my field and but
how is this mix of challenges just from
from cities right that the many things
they have to manage affecting
creating problems or synergies for you
i'm usually i guess i'm pessimistic on
the av timeline
because other than these
highly structured environments like ag
and mining and maybe some limited
applications in urban centers
i'm not one of those people that would
tell you that we're going to have a lot
of autonomous vehicles soon
i think it's actually more like around
15 to 20 years away
that
the 2021 thing that lyft talks about in
my mind smells like 2035 and 2040.
and that's
equally as unscientific it just
i know where we are in engineering
development and we're not going to be
there by the end of the year
at scale but other predictions i would
say
we will get better at managing
the human and machine interaction
i think one of the
maybe underreported challenges of this
decade is
how humans get along with machines which
have increasing amount of intelligence
and where this usually ends up is people
fall asleep or they don't pay attention
and they crash into the back of a fire
truck or something like that because
they thought they could that their
vehicle was going to be better than it
really was
and
this is i think one of the actually
bigger problems for the near term is
how do you demand that
systems like this have an understanding
of what the driver is doing and if the
driver isn't paying attention or isn't
awake or
you know is in the back like playing
video games
can you really bring them back or can
you change the system somehow
so
those ideas i think are actually
really interesting to see play out over
the next decade and in commercial
vehicles
with the way that insurance is priced i
actually think a pretty reliable
prediction would be by the end of
this decade you really won't be able to
run a commercial vehicle without some
sort of driver monitoring handshake
just for the purposes of pricing that
risk
and how that impacts the passenger car
market
i think it would i would like for us to
get to something like that but we also
have such a
john wayne-like
idea of ourselves in the united states i
don't know if passenger cars
will ever get to something that as
big brother as that even though it might
actually save lives yeah yeah this
reminds me what do you see as some of
the
um biggest barriers is it this mindset
could be one of them regulations just
the long-term
need for capital what what all
in your experience that the biggest
barriers
for
the advancements in transportation that
you mentioned
one of the things that a lot of these
cities need
right now
companies aren't really incentivized for
so what i mean by that is the way to
make money in the car business is by
selling trucks and utilities
particularly united states
so
the things we talked about the beginning
of our discussion cities need
better bike lanes and better sidewalks
and smaller vehicles that don't cost a
lot of money
it's actually just totally opposite from
the way that
the where the profit centers are in the
automobile business
and so that's why i think it's
interesting to study the electric the
small electric vehicle makers because
they're actually starting to
peek through the canopy
and find that there are really great
consumer experiences that might have
potentially good margin associated with
them
that could
could be new leaders so
the limitations i think are the dominant
players in the united states at least
are
not necessarily incentivized for better
smaller vehicles they're actually
incentivized for
the things that have we're used to which
is to say there's about eight parking
spots for every car
and it's there's cheap parking
everywhere and there's cheap financing
so why not just get the bigger suv the
next time you buy a car
and
that's great for the profits of those
companies
it doesn't necessarily answer the
question of how it makes transportation
safer for
a lot of people in cities or suburbs
yeah
that's interestingly actually very
similar incentives around buildings
actually i have to say
it's uh now surprising or not totally
surprising but interesting for me to
hear that
so you should go to some questions that
the students have asked yeah sure so the
top
ranked question um is which companies do
you think will capture the most value as
a result of the widespread rollout of
autonomous vehicles will it be the
incumbent car makers electric vehicle
companies like tesla tech giants like
google and apple platforms like uber and
lyft or totally new startups
i'm going to answer it as if they're
like really at scale
i don't think you mean like next year
but like when
if autonomy is delivered to vehicles
like people have been talking about
who will capture the most
margin that's your question
and
my take on this is actually it's
probably going to be something that's
integrated into
the building of the vehicle so i know
that in the
three or four years ago there was this
argument of oh this is the airline
industry and
uber and lyft will essentially be the
airline
and it doesn't really matter what kind
of car they have if it's a boeing or if
it's an airbus you don't really ask that
question before you get on a plane
and i actually think this is
that's not true for vehicles if i get
out of the airport and i'm with my kids
and
i have a decision to make do i get in
like a nameless faceless automobile or
do i get in a toyota
i think it's like there's no question i
get in a toyota if the if so much of the
vehicle control
is
designed from these companies
now if
uber and lyft actually
do make autonomous vehicles and
if you've been if you watch what
happened with uber last year they pretty
much have gotten out of their robotics
business
and it wouldn't surprise me if lyft
eventually got to the same conclusion
they seem to be just on this like thin
layer of being an airline for a lot of
these parts of on-demand life which is
perfectly fine it might be great so i
think to answer your question a lot of
the value is going to roll up to
somebody who can combine a little bit of
the service experience as well as the
manufacturing and right now and probably
for the next 15 years there aren't that
many companies that are willing to stick
it out to spend
10 figures 11 figures to bring these
ideas to market like you have google and
baidu and
ford vw and there's not many and how
many of them are going to be able to
like stick through it through multiple
ceo changes and board of directors
changes a decade from now
probably
an incredibly small number i guess the
in that description of what i gave you
is probably like how you would design
the tesla
point of view on autonomy right which is
look
we have built the vehicle
we'll put this thin layer of service on
top of it which is you can access the
car
and so i'm not necessarily optimistic
that tesla will be able to meet any of
its
public sort of promises around timelines
for their system but i do think that is
probably the most compelling
vision of it right now even if it might
take another 10 years
next one is what kind of ancillary
services do you have your eye on as
autonomous vehicles become a closer
reality
the commitments that these companies
have made to zero emission
i think you won't be able to operate a
tnc or ride healing business without an
electric vehicle by 2030. so some of
them have said that i think
if you read between the lines probably
they will allow those vehicles to be
hybrids but in a lot of the big cities
it will be zero emission battery
electric vehicles only and so therefore
one of the ancillary things is going to
be their own charging network so
what sort of
how will they support the electric
vehicles
is a really interesting thing that
i actually think that a lot of the tnc's
are going to have their own charging
network
or if they're not their own they're
going to
have almost like reservations within
existing networks so that they can
guarantee their drivers can use stuff
pretty frequently because
it's interesting if you look at the age
of a lot of the lyft and uber vehicles
a lot of them today are somewhere
between 5 and 10 years old
and
so if you were to say if i have to run
an ev in san francisco if i drive for
lyft in 2030
it means that vehicle is getting
built and sold like in the next year or
two so it's like a chevy bolt or maybe a
model a used model 3 or something like
that
so
the vehicles are right here right now
they have a 250 mile 300 mile range
they're going to need a lot of charging
infrastructure help that's one thing the
other thing is i don't think that the
these ride hailing companies and
therefore the autonomous vehicle
companies
have really done
as much around kind of education and
communicating
the benefits of these systems to be
honest like when most people now think
of autonomous vehicles i think
they think of the uber crash and the
fatality and the way that these
companies have been
run by people who don't necessarily
think about safety and i would take the
opposite tact which is
if i was running
an av business
i would go into a city and say i'm going
to fund
the creation of bike lanes and wider
sidewalks and i'm going to be the
ultimate advocate for
pedestrian safety and when i do that at
no small cost to me
i want to have the exclusive permit to
operate avs in this
geo for the next two years
and actually
incentivize these safety creating things
in cities
so not necessarily like a service but
i think it's a big opportunity around
avs that
some of these companies are going to
have to do let's do one more question i
think actually combining the next two
popular questions in my mind they go
together
and actually builds i think
on this point
so one question is how do you think
about the phony ethical dilemma
surrounding ai algorithms for autonomous
vehicles
and the other is what are the key safety
concerns that are preventing us from
widespread level 5 autonomous vehicles
there's i think some connection there's
also some different aspects of course
but you can probably answer them
sure
combined there thanks both for your
questions and the first one i will say
most
creators of these systems don't actually
have a really good answer for you when
you ask them how do you know your system
is safe enough to deploy
which i think is actually much
more important of a question to ask them
is does the engineering team feel it's
ready and so there's like a philosophy
around how you actually understand as a
company what's safe
there's a standard um called ul4600 that
might be interesting for you all to
check out and it's basically the first
time
ul has done
any sort of like framework around safety
for automated systems a lot of it
applies specifically to vehicles but you
could actually use it for a lot of other
automated systems and it's worth
thinking about and where my answer to
this is i actually don't believe that
understanding the safety case for these
rollouts is really well defined by
current regulations
at the state level and certainly at the
federal level where there's almost
little to say about automated vehicles
today
and so the first step i think in getting
comfortable with
how these systems actually work from an
ethical perspective
is understanding how the people who have
released them have defined safety and
i don't think that there's necessarily
like one
dogma around this but
i actually don't know if people have
ever really talked about this the same
way you might think about understanding
how somebody like song exploder style
like how you made a song there's not a
really good
set of
experiences i have had with people who
are the product managers of these
programs who have talked about their
safety case so that's
one thing and
maybe part of this is just we don't have
a lot of understanding at the policy
level of what automotive safety in
systems really means
unfortunately in the united states
there's been
well there's been more law
at the state level than at the federal
level i think that's probably going to
change
startups have benefited from that by the
way because if you're an autonomous
vehicle startup
there's a state you could have found in
the last couple years that would have
allowed you to run a vehicle on the road
and so for you as a startup trying to
make your way in the world that might
have been a good thing
is it the right sort of ethical
framework to think about these
how we're rolling on autonomous vehicles
absolutely not
i'm punting a little bit on your
question michelle just because i think
that is like the fundamental perspective
on this that
i haven't heard yet and then
when it comes to
the second question this is something i
hear a lot which is oh yeah everything's
ready just we need
the attorneys to sign off in it and
i think that's it's underselling
frankly like how much work is yet to be
done
and there's this interesting thing
happening with the sae levels right now
so if you look at
the essay created these six levels of
automation and there's about to be a
seventh which is that there's a level
2.5 or two plus and and
what it essentially says is this is like
a level three system in the sense that
the vehicle is taking over
the
both the latitudinal and longitudinal
control but the human is still
responsible for
what that vehicle does and if it leapt
into this next phase which is the
vehicle or the manufacturers responsible
for it that would be a level three and
by some people's definition
and
i think this is
a really like a problematic phase for
how these vehicles are being developed
and i
have talked to many people at car
companies who
they know that their systems aren't
ready and i think the moment at which a
lot of car companies are a lot of
manufacturer these systems say
not only is it ready but we'll take the
full
legal responsibility for it that's
actually when you know the engineering
team has been done is complete
so it's like a big towel in my mind but
thank you for your question
yep thank you riley for all your
at least for me very
wonderful insights
maybe one
more plenary tip if the students do one
or two things at stanford if they're
interested in this space what should
they do what do you think they should do
or maybe something i mean
yeah what an
amazing place to be to do this stuff
because there's actually a lot of
transportation
entrepreneurship at stanford
one insight would be
i think that you have the opportunity to
work for a really interesting company
without going too far
certainly all the car companies and
people try to recruit all of you guys
but
you could work for a ride alien company
or something like that which would be
really fascinating
i do think
there are so many different layers of
transportation think of it like the
the taco bell seven-layer burrito within
any component that we're talking about
logistics
ride hailing
there's
an opportunity for you to be an expert
in one of those areas that where you
might be passionate about
and
i know for a fact that there's just not
enough
people in all these other emerging parts
of the ecosystem whether it's hydrogen
for long-haul stuff or it's charging a
lot of people have gone into
ride hailing and robo taxi over the last
five years
as almost like robo taxi generalists and
i would challenge you to just be a
javelin thrower be a very specific
like application of your passion and
your resources
and you will get noticed easier if you
do that and also i think you'll find
some really cool opportunities